this week congress took a major step by
allowing some of its own staffers to
unionize
so far the decision would apply only to
the house not the senate it comes amid a
reinvigorated movement over labor rights
as workers take on some of the biggest
corporations in the country
here's congressional correspondent
nicole killian
for a decade working on capitol hill
seemed like a dream job for rich lucetti
every day you come to work in the
capitol you're working in a living
museum the same time the first job that
i worked in i remember i
made thirty three thousand dollars a
year i was splitting an apartment with a
college friend
it wasn't uncommon to get a meal at
seven eleven he finally reached a
breaking point working long hours
working through covid and then on top of
that the january 6th insurrection it
just got to a point where
i enjoyed my 10 years here but it was
time for me to go last year turnover
among house staffers reached its highest
rate in at least 20 years a recent
report found roughly one in eight
congressional staffers make less than a
living wage
after a viral outcry for months over low
pay lack of diversity and hostile work
environments on the anonymous instagram
account dear white staffers the
resolution
is adopted
the house approved a resolution this
week allowing nearly 10 000
congressional workers the right to
organize and collectively bargain it's a
really big deal just to say as a matter
of law
you
staffers of capitol hill
have the right to form a union michigan
congressman and 11 introduced the
measure why do you think it's gaining
traction now
you know i think that this is part of a
much broader movement in society
so starting with teachers then you had
workers in industry after industry start
to form unions
amazon now we have starbucks the coffee
giant recently announced new pay hikes
and benefits for employees but excluded
those who have formed unions at its
stores
this spring amazon workers established
the first union in the online retailer's
nearly 28-year history at a warehouse in
staten island you got to treat our
people right drawing attention and
scrutiny from lawmakers you've
determined amazon is a piece of crap
company
that's your political bias it's not a
democrat or republican thing
it's a workers thing for rich the action
by congress is an important first step
if you're asking do i wish i had been a
union member 10 years ago when i was
making 33 000 a year absolutely people
are working longer and longer hours
right now for less money on top of that
inflation is just running away and
there's a recognition that people who
work hard should be able to provide for
themselves and for their country for cbs
saturday morning nicole killian
washington